[Music]
Games are amazing. You
can do things that cannot be achieved in real life.
Now you can create a character. It's your
first time logging in. It's
new again. It's
fun to ride the rhythm. I
feel like I've found the path I need to take.
In other words, it's
not just another time, right?  Well, you'll have to fight me once.
[Music] I have
n't heard anything about this, but
you're the one being exposed. I don't want to stand out like this, so why did this happen? I have
just one chance to make you feel special. I have to decide here.  It's
not worth it to be at the party
[Music] That's fine, is
n't it? It's not
going to diminish [Music] It's only your dream. People who get involved stay up all night. I have a
job, so I might as well go to
sleep. I'm an old man's VRMO active period.
2023  Broadcast starts from October